I am so excited that you're here. - (Applause)
I really, really. I've been so looking forward to this,
and we're just so excited to have a conversation with you.
I'm so inspired by your
entrepreneurial ways.
And I feel like I'm so glad that you wrote the book about it
(mumbles)
= because I think people really want to have a guide
in this world of how they too, themselves
could figure out how to navigate business.
You know, in the beginning,
I was a resistance to doing anything like in
the self-help area, because I felt like
the people that usually do that kind of
see themselves as experts.
Right
And then when I get a chance to talk about some of the
mistakes I made,
it kind of made me comfortable with doing it.
Cause then it was like to prevent people from making similar
mistakes to me.
It's what made me actually like
the category a little better.
Well, you started executive producing a show called Power.
I feel like as a consumer that you single handedly,
like I just turned British too, (laughing)
that you single-handedly really made me focus on
Starz Network. You really put them on the map.
You really put them to the forefront.
And that must be a very good feeling.
It's cool. Like when the network,
when you go go there in the early stages and you kind of,
and it blossoms and grows,
then they they'll start to listen to you.
You know, they start
to want more content from you because they've had
success with everything that you offer. But Power
it, I didn't, but the success of the series,
I convinced them that they,
that it was a universe like Marvel,
like did I can do multiples and that people appreciate it
and enjoy it. And, and Starz, they came to mandate.
It's a, it's a premium woman's mandate.
So it's like, they look at the content
from a different perspective and lens
and they saying it has to be for-for women for premium.
We have to have strong female characters as that offer
something that pulls on the strings or your heart,
your feelings when you're actually doing it.
So even when the story has males in it,
or they have to be attractive males like ghosts,
and like in the power series, they said, no,
you absolutely has to be attractive or get them out of here.
Interesting.
It's gotta be for women. And the men have to be hot
You were able to build a franchise, which you know,
in the industry is, is huge.
It's really everything. It,
it gives you a credibility kind of like nothing else.
And you were able to convince them that it was a universe
and you've got spinoff shows. And I mean, that's,
that's a very big feat.
Yeah. It's just, well five yeah, five shows.
Five shows! (audience applauding)
Now, I want to ask about the new and latest
and greatest BMF in your franchise belt at Starz.
Yeah, I'm excited about it. These guys,
they went on to be huge drug dealers,
hugely successful and their choices when you they're both
brothers, Terry and Meech Flannery.
And when you go back into the, the origin story of it,
that they come from a Christian family that struggled with
one child making the decision
to do things that they felt like was
going in the wrong direction.
And his brother just followed him into it. And it's,
it's a, it's a family drama,
but it's complex because of the choices of the children.
And they grow into full-blown adults.
And the things that they say that you'll get when you choose
that lifestyle, you being dead or in jail or where
or what actually took place. But you know,
they did the indictment felon in 2005 and they would see 30
years a piece.
Oh my gosh, I I've been watching the show.
It's it's, I'm glad you're not, you know,
putting a veneer on it. You're telling it like it is.
You're talking about a true story. It's shot beautifully.
It's very cinematic.
It's very dynamic. You actually directed an episode
Episode 7.
Who happens to have someone in it. Who-
Marshall Mathers. I got Eminem to come on.
Eminem. Yeah.
I heard he just texts you random texts throughout the day.
He does call me every now and then
Can I ask what a said 'random Marshall Mathers text' is?
Oh, he might see something I'm doing like,
like I'm on the Drew Barrymore show and he'd be like,
yo, you was right there? How was it?
Like, he'll say something to me.
Should we text him right now?
Is that awkward?
Gonna say, I'll give you my phone
Okay, wait, here.
Does he like videos, or does he prefer words?
Let's put the video.
Okay. Okay.
See, this is how good I am at this.
Okay.
Oh, you look good in that. He gonna like this.
Oh, I do? Okay, thank you.
Um, hi, Marshall. We just felt compelled to text you.
Yeah. We live on TV. This big dog status stuff
going on here. - Here's everybody
saying hello, and because I found out
you send Curtis random texts.
We thought we would send you one.
Yeah. And look, I'm sending you videos with really hot,
attractive women in them. You need to
send me something back. I'd like to see a video in return.
That's right, absolutely. Oh my god we love you! Bye!
(audience applauding) (Drew and Curtis laughing)
Oh my gosh. I was like, this is so fun and surreal.
Wait til you see, he gonna owe me big time.
Well, I'm so glad that you guys are such geniuses
and that you're friends and collaborating,
and putting wonderful stuff out into the world in such
multifaceted ways. We actually have a clip of this truly.
eye-opening, amazing show. Please take a look.
Hey yeah, Ma don't forget.
I need money for that Bablo trip.
We'll talk about it later.
That's what you said last week.
Hey look, Nikki. Don't even trip. I got you.
We not taking your money.
Pops, just for our school field trip.
Did I stutter?
Terry, how was school today?
It was good
We going to be on the honor roll again, right?
Yes sir. - Guess your last semester wasn't no fluke.
It's truly a beautifully shot show. - Thank you
Thank you so much.
BMF airs Sundays on Starz.
It has just been such a blast to hang, play, talk,
everything. - This has been so much fun, like I've done
I just did Jimmy Kimmel, he ain't as cool as you.
Oh my god!
50!
BMF airs Sundays on Starz.